I ever worked welcome everybody
I told you I'd be louder than I thought
I would be my name is dancer Uli and I'm
joined here by separate ever ahem today
not bad right welcome to the last
session of Google cloud next this is for
you guys I
I predicted when I saw the schedule that
we would have no one in the last session
so I'm very very impressed that every
one of you for actually making it and
before we get started I want to thank
the people who in the back have been
working really hard they're the only
ones who work really hard of this whole
thing thank you guys for all your work
so Seth and I are here today to talk
about CENTAC ating service to service
calls with Google Cloud endpoints and
that's what you guys are here for right
right yeah okay who want to drone anyone
want a drone in this room anyone win
anything good down down the floor
nothing oh except did you bring prizes I
did yeah whoever stays till the end of
the talk will get a prize okay
besides the prizes that we don't have
this is what we're going to be talking
about today first I'm going to get
started by talking a little bit about
the difference between authentication
and authorization to make clear what
we're talking about we are talking about
authentication today and I just want to
be clear on what that means and I want
to talk about real scenarios why this
matters to you and where you might be
already needing this where you might be
using it or where you might use it in
the future I do want to talk about Cloud
endpoints itself for a little while I
don't like to make product pitches but
this is a product that's undergone a
bunch of changes in the last year and I
want to make sure you guys are all up to
speed on where we are right now but then
we're going to spend the bulk of this
session in that that let's get to it
bullet point this is a 200 level session
I don't know what that means to you guys
but to me it means to get to see some
code so that's going to come up on stage
and he's going to show you exactly how
you configure endpoints to to secure
your api's and exactly what you need to
do to to generate calls to make those
and we should leave plenty of time at
the end for Q&A and get you out the door
on time so everybody makes their plane
back to what Moscow tonight not tonight
probably
okay so authentication versus
authorization those of you who came in
here on an airplane when you when you
got to an airport somewhere you had to
produce a passport and that passport is
identification and it is used
essentially to authenticate you a
authentication token is a token that is
generated by someone that we trust and
positive an authority that we trust and
positively identifies an individual or
an API call and it's different than
authorization not dedication just says
this is me it's like your identification
this is me and this is Who I am it alone
doesn't enable you to do things but then
it can be used to authorize you so for
example if you've got that in a visa you
might be allowed to enter a country if
you've got a driver's license that
identifies you it's authentication but
it also authorizes you to to operate a
motor vehicle in the state of California
so what we're talking today is about
authentication and the key thing to note
there is that you cannot do
authorization if you haven't done
awesome Takai ssin I can't decide if
you're allowed to walk through that door
right now if you don't have a badge on
that tells me who you are so so today
we're going to be talking about
authentication now when might you use
this well how many people develop mobile
api's when you have mobile apps right
those mobile apps make calls back to
napi frequently right that's one of the
primary use cases that we've seen for
endpoints over the last couple years but
what we've learned in talking to our our
customers is that they've got a mobile
API and that's we'll talk a little bit
about user oscillator but behind that
almost always more frequently than we
thought there are other services and
that that mobile API that received that
call from the mobile app is is then
making calls to other back-end systems
so there are ways to authenticate users
and we'll talk a little bit about them
later but you've got a something in your
in your mobile app that's going to
generate a credential and you want to
send that over to your your back-end and
have that thing validate that
that of that auth token and validate
that you know who the user is that made
that call but the issue is that token
that was generated to make that call
most frequently you don't want that to
be the kind of authentication that you
use on those other surfaces that your
that your mobile API is calling you
actually would like those services to
reject that token and the reason you
want to do that is that you don't want
that guy who has the ability to get a
hold of one of those tokens to be able
to call your back-end system generally
their back-end systems for a reason and
you don't intend for them to be exposed
externally you don't want people calling
them so you need to actually have
different auth and then you do on that
front end API and if you're using App
Engine or App Engine App Engine flexible
environments all of those you know IP
addresses are visible from the internet
and so you need something to be able to
protect it and and to take a different
auth token than you're sending from your
mobile app anyone has ever heard the
word micro-services yes you've been in
this industry for the last two years you
hear it four times a day you look at it
hacker knows it's people talk about it a
lot and we have a lot of customers who
are implementing them we've been
developing we didn't use the term micro
services at Google but but at Google
we've been we've been doing this for you
know a decade or so and quite famously
internally at Google we have a flat
network we don't we don't protect
resources from other resources via the
network everything can address
everything else however every single
call that we make on our on our network
is made with authentication tokens so
that we can identify which service is
making a call and we can validate yes
that that is a caller that I trust and
the other time you might be doing this
and something we're seeing a lot with
endpoints today is customers who are not
just developing services in Google and
maybe GCE maybe gke GAE but not just in
Google but they're also running things
on premises and and they're developing
services that need to contact each other
whether it's calling from from GCP back
to their on-premises services or calling
from their on-premises services up to
GCE some people attempt to assault put
security in here with networking but
that
be very difficult and if you are
exposing IPS it's critical that you can
authenticate those calls and it gets
more complicated in this and it's almost
hard to believe but I'm told that we
have customers who are running services
in the middle of the Amazon sounds
unbelievable but it's true and again
there it's even it's even more going to
be more difficult to solve this security
problem with with any sort of networking
issue setting up firewalls that can let
help you cloud the cloud and on-premise
is very difficult so it's just another
situation where you you want to be able
to authenticate who your callers are so
that's a bunch of reasons why you need
service to service authentication today
now I want to talk a little bit about
cloud endpoints before SEP shows us how
it can solve all your problems
so how many people have used cloud
endpoints in the past in the past two
years when you might know it as a
feature of App Engine because that's
what it was for a couple years was a
Java framework in a Python framework
that you could use in App Engine that
had had a few different features but was
limited to Java Python and App Engine
well ever since last fall and now
generally available we have really added
a lot to the feature set and first of
all we made it so it's not just a App
Engine feature anymore this is a product
in cloud that can be used with any of
our compute backends and it's not just
used as an API framework but it's got
these additional features that let you
protect monitor and scale your API so
one of the key components is what we
call a distributed api gateway and this
is an architecture that we're now we've
been using at Google now for a couple of
years for our API we used to have an API
proxy and every call that you made to
WOA WOA P is calm went through a proxy
and that did things like authentication
and monitoring and logging and we used
all those systems internally but we
found that the extra network hops added
latency and dealing with lots and lots
of configuration that this thing had to
know about was difficult as well so we
move to an architecture where our proxy
is actually a very thin proxy that gets
deployed with each back-end so instead
of having a proxy of fat proxy that's in
the middle and does a bunch of work then
forwards calls we do
boy in a container with each back-end
the proxy so calls can get routed
directly to the backend and the proxy
can can perform that same work there we
find it it's a very very performant and
very scalable endpoints is an open
source it's based on nginx which is an
open source proxy and is uses the same
architecture sits on came on top of the
same services we use for our api's
endpoints is also deeply integrated with
with GCP so if you're using our App
Engine frameworks its built-in if you
using App Engine flexible environment
our proxy is built-in if you're using
gke we have a container that you can
drop into your deployment and of course
you can take our proxy and drop it on
GCE - so it's deeply integrated with it
with the backend it also sends all of
your monitoring metrics to Google Cloud
console where you have dashboards it
sends all your logs to stackdriver
logging I use a stack driver tray so
it's for people who are developing on
Google and and developing new
applications whatever language you're
using it can it can add these features
that we're going to show today so we're
talking about authentication today and
as I mentioned it also does good logging
and I think step is going to show you a
little bit about what the monitoring
looks like later on and it's very very
scalable and and it's also very very
performant we find that at scale it
tends to add less than a millisecond of
latency to your to your API requests
many competing solutions add one or even
two orders of magnitude more than that
and again to emphasize this is not an
app engine feature anymore you can use
it with any language on any of our
compute backends Google functions coming
soonish so this is kind of what the
architecture looks like you can place
your calls from anywhere here we show
them from an Android app an iOS app a
browser of course it can be another
service but all of your your web traffic
is routed through this proxy it's an
engine X based proxy and that's the
proxy that actually does the work and
decides whether or not a call gets
through that thing receives configs
from a service we call the Google
service management API and then at
runtime it's checking in with something
called the service control API and
that's the thing that saying hey is this
API key valid or can this project call
your project and it's also reporting
your metrics to Google Cloud logging and
and that's the thing that sends the data
up to the dashboard when calls go
through they get forward to your
back-end and if a call is rejected say
it's not authenticated it never gets to
your back-end about a year and a half
ago when we really started saying hey we
want to handle any language it was
clearly clear to us that we needed an
IDL that could describe these API when
we stepped away from the framework world
we need a way for you to tell us your
ate what your API is no matter what
language or you're writing it and so we
looked around at the different ideals
that existed at the time and we saw that
swagger really had a lot of traction and
we decided that we would adopt swagger
for this project and just about the time
that we started working with them they
announced that they were forming Lior
they told us that they were forming the
open API initiative so we became one of
the founding members of the open API
initiative along with a lot of other
industry heavyweights and are now
brothers-in-arms Appaji to join this
initiative that owns the open API
specification so we're using the open
API spec not just to describe the
surface of your API but also the config
for how you want it how you want us to
manage it so you use extensions in the
open API spec to say hey these methods
need auth or use an API key here and we
really like that we really think it's a
powerful and kind of imperative way if
we describe the way you want us to
manage your API we also work with GRP
see anyone here using G RPC yet a few
anyone heard about G RPC knew this
transport that we're using heavily for
our own API s well if you are using G
RPC then you'll find that there's
probably really only one one proxy out
there that is really doing API
management with it you can define your
API and in proto for G RPC and then you
give us a yamo that describes the
configuration again how you want us to
manage it what you want
what sort of up you want and in will
manage your gr PC ap is as well speaking
of standards for authentication we've
chosen JSON web tokens which are
pronounced jot for non non obvious
reasons but jots and and you know open
ID Connect is kind of the kind of as
become a standard for authentication and
that's where we're using for
authentication as well we've got a
couple of providers that we're working
with it's a standard you can you can
write them yourself but if you're using
fire rates are at zero we can we can
validate those and that's all I wanted
to get through and now I want to hand
this over to SEP who's going to show us
how the whole thing works great thanks
man so as I mentioned we have the best
demo of the conference save for last I
just hope that it works what I would
like to show you is a simple nodejs
backend let's actually switch back to
the slide for a moment that implements
the REST API and I'll show deploying
that REST API on to App Engine flex and
then I'll talk about how we can turn
this back end into an endpoints API and
we'll see what benefits we get from that
in terms of the features that I
mentioned namely logging and monitoring
and then the focus of the talk is
authentication so we'll talk about how
to secure that API and make it so that
all the clients who want to call it have
to provide authentication tokens and
I'll talk about what the clients would
look like in a different language so
imagine that the node.js back-end is one
of my services and on the other side on
the client side I'll have a Python
application and the Python application
wants to call the nodejs api's and I'll
show what that code would look like from
GCE if you want to run it from the
Google compute engine or any of the
other compute slat forms that GCP has
and I'll also show similar code that
runs from outside of GCP or from my
laptop and we'll talk about the
trade-offs so with that let's go to the
code please step you did a good job of
not interrupting me I promise not to do
so well that's okay yes you want to take
whole or you have
since computer interrupting so let's
take a look at the North code first it's
very simple about 20 lines and it's
based on no J's Express so we have a few
lines here that define a rest api it's a
post method for the api that i've called
echo it basically expects some JSON
content to come as the requested
validator that it is JSON and it just
returns that I caused it back in the
response now you could have multiple
other methods here and you know expand
your API to have get calls post cause
delete calls or multiple different paths
for whatever your application might be
and there's nothing Google specific
about this you could write the same
exact code in any other language you
could write it in no J's without using
Express and I'm mentioning that to
emphasize the fact that with endpoints
you will be able to use any language
that you want any framework that you
want you're not limited to a certain
number of languages or frameworks so
that's all with the code let's go back
and think about from the clients
perspective what we need to communicate
to the client to be able to call this
API right we are surely not going to
share the node.js implementation code
with them and you know any documentation
we provide them is probably going to be
out of date and not convey the full
message of what's in the contents of the
requests what they should expect in
their responses for that we will use
open API the open API spec for this
simple API that has one method it's also
rather simple it has one path for the
echo method it shows that it's a post
method and then it has some
documentation specific fields like
description that can be parsed by open
API tools like the swagger UI and it can
also be used to generate client
libraries for calling this API
rest of it is about what the responses
would look like at 200 response is
defined to have this type of message in
it an equal message and the equal
message at the bottom is defined here as
a message that has a field and that
field will have a string value on it so
you know rather simple I just want to
draw your attention to the host field
here I've named the API echo API without
off at the end for endpoints keyboard
after is a reserved keyword then you see
my project ID the Google Cloud project
ID so the name of this API is unique
because it's scoped into the project IDs
that are unique and I can have multiple
different endpoints API is in one
project so I want you can I serve this
from a different URL you can yes this is
not the DNS record that you'll be
calling your API with because you might
want to have your endpoints API be
backed by basically backends deployed on
different computer forms at the same
time for the sake of this demo I'll be
deploying on App Engine flex but you
might want to deploy on Google compute
engine or basically kubernetes on other
cloud providers or even on your own firm
data centers and endpoints should work
in all of those scenarios so let's go
out of this open API spec and run a
g-cloud command and g-cloud as i'm sure
you / whose use g-cloud before great GOI
doesn't show you where is the CLI for
almost all of Google Cloud products and
I'll be running this g-cloud command
that uploads the open API specification
to the control plane for endpoints some
running G cloud service management
deploy and then open API diamo so what's
happening right now is the open API is
sent to the control plane the control
plane takes a look at it and validates
it so it looks for any mistakes and
inconsistencies it also compares it to a
style guides that we have
we've published as the style guide for
how to design your api's so that they're
hopefully future proof and they're
consistent and after it's done
persisting this copy of the open API
spec it will return a unique identifier
for that copy of it in case I go to make
changes to my local copy of the open API
spec this immutable instance of it is
persisted on the control plane so if
anyone's used App Engine flicks before
you'll know that it has a aptoide llamo
simple configuration file that basically
tells App Engine and tells g-cloud
what's runtime environment it should use
in this case it's no js' and the
environment is flexed because the same
command is used to deploy to App Engine
standard and App Engine flex all of
added to this apt or diamo file in order
to turn endpoints on is three lines and
the three lines are endpoints API
service the name that I draw your
attention to in the open API yamo file
and the unique config ID so for the demo
I'll be showing two different endpoint
services side-by-side so we can compare
them but let me paste this here let's
copy it again
and paste it here so this is what Dan
was talking about with deep integration
into App Engine flex this configuration
is all I have to add and I can go and
deploy my App Engine app the same
standard way that I always do when a new
G car active y-yeah sorry
and anyone who's used App Engine flicks
will tell you that this will take quite
a few minutes to finish but I want to
draw your attention to the URL that it
spits out at the end to say the
deployment has completed and you can
call your back-end that this address so
I'm going to cancel this because I've
already deployed it and I don't want to
keep you waiting
and instead I'll do a curl command
against the already deployed endpoint so
its curl it has a single header that
says the application JSON is the format
of the request and I'm sending it some
data this is message and hello next 2017
so sure enough the backend is deployed
it returns the same data that I sent it
Wow yes awesome
thank you this part of it you could have
done even without endpoints so why did
we upload the open API spec what did we
get in addition to what we could have
done before
well let's go to the developer console
and navigate to the endpoints tab
endpoints alongside the compute engine
App Engine has its own page on the
developer console and you can see the
different endpoint services I have this
first one is the one we looked at so far
echo API without off so let's go to that
one you can see that in monitoring
dashboard as well as log messages have
already been propagated for this
endpoints API now the metrics and the
logs that are being published our API
specific there are Layton sees that were
basically measured for each request
there are error ratios as well as
response codes and the metrics
and at the bottom here we have links to
the logs that were published for these
requests so if I click on one of these
links it will take me to stackdriver
logging and I can take a look at one of
the structures log messages that was
published and see that it has a JSON
payload it shows that the HTTP method
was opposed the URL was the echo method
and it has API specific information
about the request size response size and
latency and so on I could spend the rest
of the talks is playing with log viewer
here because it's pretty cool whose use
log viewer before great so you guys
already know about it
people who are who are using App Engine
are used to getting request log but if
you're running something in compute
engine today this doesn't come for free
you're not getting this with if you're
using container engine or compute engine
but by putting endpoints in front of
your API you are gonne all of a sudden
you're going to be getting logs for
every API call it comes in and and and
the dashboard that Sepp showed has some
graphs that look similar to what you see
in App Engine but what we showed at the
bottom is it's all broken down by method
so you cannot just see hey the 98
percentile safer for our API is high you
might see there's just one particular
method that has a percent latency that's
high or that's getting increased to
error rates so it's giving you a higher
fidelity of metrics and a higher
fidelity of logs because we know about
your API exactly that so that's pretty
cool we just uploaded our open API
specification which we were going to
write anyways in order to communicate
the surface of our API to our clients
and we got monitoring and logging
effortlessly but the focus of the talk
is authentication as you noticed I made
the curl command from my laptop and this
API is open on the public Internet
whoever has this URL can go call it now
so how do I secure it have multiple
options for doing that I could go and
write a lot of no js' code in order to
expect authentication tokens in the
requests that are coming in and
basically verify the signature of those
authentication tokens and do all the
hard work myself or I can configure
endpoints to expect and require
authentication for my API and
not make any back-end nodejs changes so
you know which one seems like the easier
path let's take a look at the other open
API file that I have here to illustrate
how many lines we've added and the first
section is all the same the only thing
I've changed is the name of the API to
say echo API with off this time the rest
is all the same except at the bottom
I've added about 10 lines the lines of
added first there's a security
definition which is an open API concept
and the name of given it is Google ID
token and I've given it a few different
fields the important one to call out
here is that for the demo I'm using the
Google identity provider and the issue
around configuring is accounts Google
comm now we will talk about other
identity providers and identity provider
hubs like alt 0 firebase and other third
parties that we support as well as
custom jobs after after this part of the
demo the second part if you're familiar
with open API is simply saying that this
Google ID token security definition
should be required for all the methods
in this API alternatively I could have
required just some of the methods to
have authentication and keep the rest
either open or have multiple security
definitions here and say these methods
require that security definition those
other methods require another security
definition so we'll talk about why that
might be useful but let's exit this and
do the same thing we did before G cloud
service management Floyd this arm of an
API specification to the endpoint
control plane at the end for a few
seconds once it finishes it will give me
a configuration ID and it has persisted
this version of my open API spec and
what I'll do with that I'll copy the
configuration ID and I'll put it in the
application demo file for App Engine
just like I did previously
notice a warning message here this is
one of the validations that it's doing
it's saying that the echo method is not
protected with API keys you know it's
asking if I'm sure that I want to put
this up because then it would be
publicly accessible and it doesn't know
that I have security requirements on
this method with security definitions
but that's the nice thing about having
your open API spec validated you can see
any warnings and errors associated with
it so let me copy this configuration ID
put it in the app dog animal again I'll
comment the echo API without off section
and uncomment this section and again I
will do g-cloud app deploy to deploy the
same back-end remember we have not
changed the nodejs code at all and I
want to compare them side-by-side so
perhaps I won't promote it to the
production version of my app and maybe
I'll give it a different version let's
call it rip off and once this finishes
deploying it will give me a different
URL the URL will be with off and the
rest is the same that's why I gave it a
different version name so I've also
deployed this because I want to keep you
guys waiting let's go ahead and issue
the same crawl command against this
deployment
and sure enough this time the call
didn't go through
I got an HTTP 401 error and the error
has a message in it that says jawed
validation failed credentials were
either missing or invalid so that's
pretty cool we just secure the API it
now requires authentication and my work
here is done we can go home or maybe we
should also take a look at the client
side as well and see how we can actually
securely call this API now well for the
client side I will demo two different
scenarios let's say you're running on
the Google compute engine and you have a
virtual machine and you're running your
Python client there and then I will show
you what it means to run it outside the
vehicle platform and either run it on
Prem or from my laptop so let's go to
the developer console for compute engine
and I have a vanilla GC instance here
and it's just sitting there doing
nothing so that's why GC is recommending
that I can either downsize it and save
some money or improve its performance
let's say to this then - it is one of my
favorite ventures by the way of cloud
console is to click the button SSH in
right and the nice thing about running
from a GC instance is that for making my
authenticated call I can take advantage
of the building credential management
features that all of the computers at
forms on GCP have so I have a service
account just like the accounts that you
and I would have as human users the
service account has some credentials it
has a private key associated with it on
this GC virtual machine those private
key those private keys for the service
accounts are readily available and I
don't have to worry about securely
copying them around or rotating them and
so on let's take a look at this GC
client code that I have it's just a few
lines of Python code
hopefully it's legible on the screen
um this is the service account that it's
using the credentials of its next demo
service account at some URL that we have
what it's doing is first it is creating
a JSON web token and the payload for the
JSON web token is here it has an issue
at field and an exploration field and
the important ones are that the issuer
is the service account the target
audience is the echo API with auth
endpoint service that I want to call and
then what the code is doing is assigning
this jot with the credentials of the
service account that it has access to on
the virtual machine then it uses that
sign jot to call the Google ID provider
and get an ID token the ID token is also
another jot it uses that jot to call the
echo API so we'll talk about why there
is a two hop step here and what the
advantages and disadvantages of doing
that are let's go ahead and test the
code first without authentication sure
enough we get the HTTP for one error and
a rather simple flag here that says
office true or yes and it is creating a
sign job
it is obtaining an ID token with that
sign jots and then it's calling the echo
API with that ID token sure enough the
course succeeds and it returns the
message that it sent it and it saying
that that's kind of cool there that
happen is it is using default these
credential management that's available
within GCE any of the compute platforms
so you're not having to maintain a
secrets file you're not having to rotate
keys that's just going to happen
automatically you sign that jot and it's
going to use the latest credential and
that will be validated by Google right
and you might say well I don't want to
run my Python client side on a Google
compute engine instance I want to run it
elsewhere you can do that too let's go
to take a look at the service account
that I just used in the Google Cloud
console so under the service account
Paige I have the next demo service
account that we just saw and I can
create a key for it when I create the
key the credentials are downloaded to my
machine take a look at the credentials
and you'll see that it has a private key
in it so this is the private key portion
and from this point on I will be
responsible for securely distributing it
to any place that I want to run my
clients on and rotating it and so on so
let's close that and let's go back to my
prompt and this is your laptop Prime and
this is my laptop we're not running in
computer engineering exactly this is
outside of the Google cloud platform
it's on the Wi-Fi that we have here and
I have a slightly different client code
written in Python for running locally
let's take a look at that again it
creates a jot the only difference is
this time it finds the judge with the
credentials that I have locally on my
machine so I have the private key and
the service account file that I will
pass into the script it finds the jobs
with that it uses that sign shot to get
an ID token and then it calls the echo
API with that ID token okay so the thing
to bear in mind is you can run this code
anywhere if you're calling from on-prem
to to Google you're calling from another
cloud provider to Google you you have to
get that key there and and you probably
have methods that you using for handling
secrets in each of those places but this
this file now is is it's an important
file and anyone who has this has the
ability to call your service so on
Google you don't have to worry about
that when you're when you're calling
when your service when he's running in
Python is running outside of Google you
have to maintain the privacy and secrecy
of this file exactly so let's go ahead
and test this one out and sure enough
the same thing if I don't give it any
credentials to call fails with an HTTP
401 if I give it the service accounts
credentials file it will create a sign
job to get an ID token and call the API
with that ID token so that's pretty cool
but it shows the advantage and
disadvantage of running your client-side
on the compute engine or App Engine or
basically the other computer platforms
that we have on GCP so we can go back to
the endpoints dashboard and see the same
graph and see the API is running side by
side this is the endpoints API with
authentication and I've been generating
some traffic against it so this one will
also have metrics and it also shows the
400 requests that were rejected because
they didn't have authentication so with
that let's go back to the slides please
so what do we just look at first we
looked at some sample nodejs code and
the quote might have easily been written
in a different language or a different
framework be sure that is implemented a
REST API and we showed how easy it was
to write an open API specification that
describes the method request responses
and documentation for that API and that
if you have the open API spec you
basically have an endpoints API and you
can get metrics logs and authentication
out of endpoints for that and of course
we saw that the calls we made before the
added authentication succeeded once we
added authentication the unauthenticated
calls with curl or with the clients
written in Python failed and the key
point here is that the response that was
HTTP 401 came from the endpoints
extensible server proxy so those
requests never actually made it to the
node.js backend and of course when we
had authentication JSON web tokens the
request succeeded and the response was
proc feedback from the nodejs back end
the few lines of code that we had to the
few lines of configuration excuse me
that we had to add to the open API spec
are repeated here the issuer which shows
was the Google ID token our issuer now
what do we do that we did that so that
any service account on the project that
I was using would be able to call the
API you might say well I don't want to
use the Google ID provider I might want
to use a third-party provider like odd
zero or I want to sign my own job well
that's also possible with the same
configuration you just have to provide
two extra lines that tell the extensible
server proxy where to get your jacques
public key and what the audiences are
for your JSON web tokens now the
advantage of doing this is that you're
no longer calling the Google ID provider
at all that you can create a sign jot
and call your API directly with that the
disadvantage is that anytime you want to
change the audiences or rotate your
credentials or we should say change the
public key URI you would need to
redeploy your back-end but the cool
thing let's look at other differences
between them the cool thing is that you
could have as I mentioned earlier
multiple different security definitions
if you're using your own sign shots and
that way do a bit of authorization to to
say the JSON web tokens that have this
audience can only call these methods in
my API the JSON web tokens that have
those other audiences can call all my
methods or these other methods of API
and of course the advantage of running
with Google ID token and on GCP is that
the credential management and rotating
of secrets is handled for you so with
that I'll hand back to then we'll talk
about firebase and of 0 and the other
features that endpoints is planning
amazing demo step amazing thank you
and before I do that I might point out
that one of the sessions you elected to
not go to right now and I just found out
this last night is our good friends from
vendetta they're customers of ours who
are in one of these other rooms right
now giving a talk on on security at
vendetta and what they're talking about
is service to service off using end
points so if you were torn between the
two you got pretty much the same it's
really the one because this is exactly
what they do when calling cloud-to-cloud
and calling within Google so we've
talked a lot about service of service
off and we talked about service accounts
or robot accounts as we call them but in
that very first kind of diagram slide I
showed I showed a mobile device right
and when a call is coming in from that
mobile device what you generally want to
know there is who's holding that mobile
device who logged into that mobile app
you guys have heard a lot about firebase
firebase is of course a great company
that we acquired a couple years ago and
I think they've done a really good job
as an acquisition at Google of kind of
maintaining a strong identity and also
finding a great place within Google in
integrating well they've really
integrated well on that mobile developer
all of the tools that Google is
producing they have they have done a
good job of kind of consolidating them
under firebase if you are using firebase
one of the features of firebase auth and
they have good client libraries that you
can use in mobile devices or web apps to
let you your users sign in and your
users can sign in with username and
password they can choose a Google auth
they can use Facebook or Twitter a bunch
of different identity providers they
have a good client library experience
for that well if you are using firebase
and you'd like to put some logic and say
run it on App Engine or or any of our
compute back-end they of course are
sending a jot token as well and of
course endpoints can validate that jot
token there's a third-party identity
solution called auth0 the lots of mobile
developers are using we work with them
as well configuration they're very very
similar because it's all job based you
basically tell us who's going to be
issuing this and there you will put your
firebase project ID and and you give the
standard address for where to get that
public
and we can we can validate those jot
token so that's the configuration you
would use for your mobile API the one
that will be called directly by that
mobile device so that's the the bulk of
the stuff that we wanted to talk about
give you a little overview of what
endpoints is talk to you about why
service to service authentication is
important when you might use it did want
to give you a glimpse of what's going to
be happening coming up we have a lot of
users we went full beta and I think in
September
we've been GA since last month we've got
a lot of people using this the great
thing about getting users using your
software as they start to tell you
what's missing and that's fantastic
feedback so we've talked a lot about
authentication well I users want
authorization we have a lot of people
asking about that and so you can bet
worth thinking pretty hard about what to
do about it also very fine control set
mentioned one of the things you can do
now is you can control you might have
some methods that you require API keys
for and some not and in his
configuration he was applying that
policy to the entire API you can do that
per method but people want it even more
fine control we have customers who who
define resources within their API and
they want to control who has access to
what resource so if I've got my
bookshelves API maybe you get access to
the history section and you get access
to the science section but I'm not going
to let you read history or you read
science so so we're looking at ways we
might do that for our users
rate-limiting comes up a lot especially
for people who are starting to think
about exposing their API to third
parties it's not such a big deal with
your mobile app you rarely want to deny
requests to your own API to your own API
but when other people start using your
API is then you do think about denying
your request we have a lot a lot other
features that that people are asking for
and that we're starting to work on so
this is an area that we're really
investing a lot in so keep your eye on
this space and with that I think you are
looking at the last slide you will look
at and next 2017 we both have Twitter
accounts I pay attention to mine a lot
and I ping him and make him pay
attention to his sometime feel free to
hit us
[Music]
you